[Musique]
donc
je pense que les Suédois
prennent de grandes responsabilités donc si vous êtes
malade, nous restons à la maison
et si nous ne le sommes pas, nous pouvons être dehors, ce
serait bien pour moi de porter un masque
bien sûr, mais si le  la recommandation
n'est pas là où
il ne faut pas le porter, mais s'ils disent que tout va
bien sans cela,
nous serons sans oui,
nous attendons s'ils décident
cela,
car s'ils ne le décident pas, je
ne le porterai pas parce que
personne d'autre ne le fait.  Je sais que l'
opinion officielle est que ce n'est pas
si nécessaire parce que si tu ne manipules pas
le masque,
ok, c'est pire que de l'avoir sur toi,
tu sais que tu peux
aussi avoir un virus sur tes doigts
[Musique]
six ouais, je veux dire,
si tu regardes quoi  l'
organisation internationale a déclaré qu'un masque facial
peut être quelque chose que vous pouvez
ajouter si vous ne pouvez pas empêcher les gens de se
rassembler et ainsi de suite, jusqu'à présent, la situation
n'a pas été comme celle-là en Suède
et en ce moment, nous avons une situation avec une
baisse rapide du nombre de cas.
sans masques faciaux, puis introduire des
masques faciaux dans cette situation n'aurait
bien sûr pas beaucoup de sens.
Roberta a dit que si nous avons une
augmentation rapide du nombre de cas si de nouvelles
connaissances arrivent,
bien sûr, nous continuons à évaluer quand le
masque facial fait réellement son effet  la différence
pour l'étalement des saisons
[Musique]
vous